>>Male Presenter: OK. Welcome everybody. I'm
really delighted to introduce our guest today,
Nick Davies, who as you all know is one of
Britain's finest journalists and a multi-award
winning. He's been Author of the Year and
Britain’s Journalist of the Year and Feature
Writer of the Year.
He's a freelancer. He's been a freelancer
for many years. He works mainly for The Guardian
and The Observer. And in recent years, he's
best known I think for his book, which he
left on some of the desks here. "Flat Earth
News," which I'll pick up a copy of and read
the blurb on.
"An award-winning reporter exposes falsehood,
distortion, and propaganda in the media."
And more recently has been very heavily involved
in bringing the story of WikiLeaks to The
Guardian and to other people around the world.
So, I think you were gonna talk mainly about
"Flat Earth News" and WikiLeaks and then at
the end we'll have time for some questions.
So, Nick thanks very much for coming and the
floor is yours.
>>Nick Davies: OK. It is an extremely unfair
arrangement. You're all eating. I haven't
eaten since God was a boy.
[laughter]
Also, I made the terrible mistake of going
on a fitness week last week in Crete. They
work you very hard in order that you become
fit. And the result is I have a twisted ankle,
a jarred wrist, a trapped nerve in my back,
and various other ailments.
[audience chuckles]
So I hope you feel sorry for me. Now, WikiLeaks.
I got very involved in it. As a result of--.
Oh my God, there's lots of people coming in
here. As a result of all the secrets that
we published last summer, a lot of people
looked at journalism and said, "This changes
everything."
And I want to argue that that's completely
wrong. What the whole WikiLeaks adventure
tells you is actually that you need conventional
journalism more than ever. And my starting
point--.
Excuse me. I'm slightly asthmatic and not
breathing terribly well. My starting point
is the subtitle of that book, "Flat Earth
News," which is that the book is trying to
explain why it is that a profession whose
primary purpose is to tell the truth so frequently
puts out stories which contain falsehood,
distortion, and propaganda, and why we so
frequently fail.
So, before I get into WikiLeaks, what happened
there and what that tells us, by way of setting
the context and maybe giving you a confession,
I want to look at what's wrong with conventional
journalism. And a lot of people from--. Let
me just explain the title of the book: "Flat
Earth News."
What that refers to is the thought that for
hundreds of years, thousands of years, most
people took it for granted that the Earth
is flat because it obviously is. But once
somebody started checking, they discovered
that what was widely accepted as being obviously
true wasn't.
Now, what I'm arguing is that the mass media
are full of those kinds of statements-- Flat
Earth stories. I mean, there are some which
are notorious, global falsehoods, like for
example, almost everything that was said about
those notorious weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq.
And a huge proportion of what we told the
world about the millennium bug was completely
false. You get into running stories. It's
terrifying, for example, to look at the war
against drugs and the way that that multi-billion
dollar operation is based on assumptions about
drugs which are actually false.
It's based, for example, on the proposition
that heroin is toxic and bad for you. The
reality is that heroin is very addictive,
but it's a benign drug. You can take an awful
lot of heroin without doing yourself any harm
at all for your entire life.
What does the damage is the black market,
which is created by the false assumption that
the heroin is bad for you. It's a ghastly
misunderstanding. And it's the media that
feeds the falsehood to the government. And
you get all these little stories that just
come and go-- the 24-hour falsehoods.
Things--. I mean, there was a lovely little
example a few months ago, just happens to
come to mind, about a woman who was appointed
to be the Chief of Police in a small town
in Mexico. Do you remember this story? It
was all about how this fortunately rather
attractive woman was gonna take on the big
drug cartels single-handed.
Great story. Now if you actually read beyond
the headline and the intro to what she said,
what she actually said is, "My responsibility
is crime prevention. I'm gonna be checking
things like whether there are bolts on windows.
If somebody tells me there's a drug cartel
in the town, I won't even report it to the
state police or the federal police, whose
job it is to look after it. It's nothing to
do with me."
Lone Woman Takes on Drug Cartel. It's a great
story. It happens to be false. Now, why do
we do this? The interesting thing is that
most outsiders who look at what news organizations
do are themselves victims of Flat Earth style
explanations as to why we get it wrong.
So, a lot of people think that we are the
victims of our proprietors, who lean down
from on high and inflict their politically
motivated lies on us. And therefore, like
good puppets, we obediently put it into print.
There is a certain amount of that which goes
on. The two words "Rupert" and "Murdock" inevitably
come to mind.
[laughter]
But actually, there's very little of it--very
little. Far, far less than people imagine
and certainly far, far too little to explain
the generality with which news media failed
to tell the truths.
A lot of people think that we are similarly
pushed around by advertisers. We need their
money. They won't give to us unless we tow
some particular line that they want us to.
I have to tell you, in the national media,
I've never come across a proven example of
that happening.
I've come across examples of advertisers occasionally
trying it on and being told to remove themselves,
but in slightly more foul language. So, what
is it that actually is going on in news organizations
that means that we are failing?
In a line, what's happening is that news organizations,
overwhelmingly in the developed world, have
been brought up by big corporations which
understandably have seen these news organizations
as a source of profit.
And therefore, they have implemented a series
of changes, which in a line have shifted the
priority so that instead of the priority being
editorial, journalistic, it is now commercial
and profit-making. And this has an enormous
range of impacts on the way we operate, almost
all of them destructive.
So, there's a big structural thing, which
is that these new owners are interested in
increasing the amount of money they can make.
There's nothing controversial about that.
So, they tend to try and cut their costs by
reducing the number of staff involved. And
they're trying to increase our output so that
they can earn more advertising.
That's a very noisy sandwich. So, we did a
big piece of number crunching when we were
researching "Flat Earth News." I hired some
innocent, long-suffering academics from Cardiff
University. Good guys. Specialists.
And one of the things they did was to go through
the annual reports of all the Fleet Street
companies, looking for information about how
many journalists were being employed on our
national newspapers--each of them. And where
there were gaps, they spoke to executives
to fill it in.
Then, I sent them off to do an extremely tedious
job, which was to go to the newspaper museum
and measure the physical space that those
journalists were filling. And we collected
all the numbers from 1985 through to the present
date. And when we crunched them all together
and took a bottom line figure, which is not
perfect, this figure, but it's a very interesting,
albeit crude, indicator.
What we found is that your average Fleet Street
journalist today is filling three times as
much space as he or she was in 1985. Now,
if you flip that 'round and look at it from
the operational point of view, the reporter's
point of view, what it means is that as a
crude average, we have only a third of the
time that we used to have to work on our stories.
And time matters. Time is the most important
working asset that reporters have. You take
time away from reporters. It's like taking
the steel away from the manufacture of automobiles.
You can't do it. And we then followed through
to look at what happens.
This is a simple structural point, right,
about commercializing news rooms. What happens
when you take time away from reporters in
that way? So, we took a sample of 2000 about
the United Kingdom, which had been published
by the best newspapers in Britain, i.e., the
quality press.
Times, Telegraph, Guardian, Independent. We
threw in The Daily Mail. You wouldn't want
to call it a quality newspaper, but it's powerful,
[audience chuckles]
so we thought it ought to be in there. So
that gave us--.
So we took two random, one-week periods, pulled
2000 stories, one at a time and asked themselves
a question, which is this: Insofar as this
story has a central, factual statement, is
there evidence that that statement has been
checked? Now, I'm right at the beginning I
said, "Our job is to try to tell the truth."
But that's our primary purpose. So, our primary
function is checking. It's just basic. This
statement is false. We don't want it. This
statement is true. We'll use it. That's the
primary function. So when you ask this question,
you know the answer you will get. It's gonna
be a 100%.
The answer they actually got was 12. 12% of
the stories in the best newspapers in the
country had shown evidence that their central
factual statements had been checked. Do you
see what happens when you start to take time
away from journalists?
OK. Taking those same 2000 stories, we did
another exercise, which was very long and
convoluted, which was to find the origin of
the raw material--the information--from which
those stories were built. Now, the answer
ought to be that the journalists are contacting
human beings and extracting information or
documents or whatever from them, that the
journalists are going out and finding it.
What we actually found was that that was true
funnily enough in the same percent. Only 12%
of the material in these stories was actually
being generated by the journalists themselves.
There was 8% where we just couldn't quite
bottom it.
We couldn't quite find out where it had come
from. It was off the record; It was obscure
or whatever. But 80% of this stuff was coming
from two, secondhand sources. The first of
those is the wire agencies-- Reuters, The
Press Association, AP. And on the other hand,
the public relations industry.
And these two overlap. A lot of material pushed
out by people like Peter Barron. We'll run
on Newswise. OK. Now, if you put all this
together, you get a picture of journalists,
instead of being active information gatherers,
going out and gathering information and checking
it, they become passive processors of material
that people provide for them.
And they don't check it. So, if the Prime
Minister wants to stand up and say there are
weapons of mass destruction all over Buckingham
Palace Road, it gets churned out and pushed
into press. We don't check it. We just take
it and put it in. I started using this word
to summarize this.
Churnalism, rather than journalism--the unchecked
recycling of second-hand material. And just
to explain, those two second-hand sources,
what's wrong with them, the wire agencies.
A lot of reporters who work for someone like
Reuters are very highly professional, very
often brave people who will go into extremely
dangerous spaces to get information.
But there are two reasons why Reuters, or
all the other agencies, won't tell you the
truth about the world. The first and most
important is that they have no idea what it
is. If you think--. Does anybody know how
many countries there are in the world? It's
a rhetorical question.
Nobody knows. But there's about 200. Is Palestine
a country? Is Taiwan a country? There are
people killing each other trying to get the
answer. But it's about 200. And I did a huge
grid, looking at all the countries where Reuters
has representatives producing television news
and text news.
So the first thing, in terms of text news--words--there
are 80 of those 200 countries where there's
nobody from Reuters, and also nobody from
the Associated Press, right? Now bear in mind
80% of news is coming from PR and wire agencies.
These are hugely significant providers of
news information.
And there are 80 of the world's roughly 200
countries where they don't have anybody. In
the countries where they do have people, generally
speaking it's one or two people in the capitol
city with tens of millions of people in the
population, thousands and thousands of square
miles.
They cannot possibly know what is going on
in their patch. For example, in October 2001,
September 2001, when the terrorist attacks
happened in New York, Reuters' representation
in Afghanistan consisted of one man who was
doing television news and text news.
And television news is even better. Of the
roughly 200 countries, there's only 80 where
they have people. Countries like, for example,
Saudi Arabia, Ireland, Canada, the Congo,
don't have anybody there. So, we get news
from there only if something really freakishly
unusual happens and the local people put it
out in whatever format and we pick it up.
So, it's inherently unlikely that Reuters
and the other agencies can tell us the truth
about the world or their patch, because they
don't know it. Furthermore, if you actually
look at the detail of what they do, they're
not interested in telling you the truth. They
do a different thing, which is accuracy.
So, what agency reporters are paid to do is
to report what people say. That's what the
good agency reporter does. Our job, as the
recipients of this agency copy, as it comes
into our newsrooms, is to check to see whether
what those people are saying is true.
But as we've discovered, that's happening
in a very small proportion of cases. So, put
those two things together, it is alarmingly
easy for people to manipulate news coverage
simply by saying whatever suits them. It flows
through the wire into our newsrooms and then
into the newspapers or telly.
And then, a lot of what it carries is product
of the public relations industry. Now, you
have to understand what's wrong with PR. To
some extent, to some small extent, PR people
lie. Don't listen to this bit, Peter. PR people
get terribly upset if you accuse them of lying.
But is it certainly my experience that if
you put a powerful PR person in a corner and
give them no other option, they will certainly
lie. 'Cause actually, more than WikiLeaks,
the thing I've been doing for the last two
or three years, is the phone hacking saga
at The News of the World.
And there is no doubt, and I'd like to say
this on the camera so that it can be repeated
so they'll know it, News International, Rupert
Murdock's News International have consistently
lied about that. And they have lied to their
colleagues and the rest of the press.
Lied and lied and lied. So, they will do it.
PR people will lie. But that's not the generality
of what's wrong with PR. Most of the time,
what they're doing is telling us truths, but
they're selecting those truths which serve
their interests. And for that reason it's
unreliable.
Just as a single example, I had an interesting
conversation when I was researching the book,
with a guy who runs the press office at one
of the big central government departments.
I won't tell you which one it is, but it's
like education or the home office or transport
or whatever.
Excuse me. And he was saying that they have
a system where. So if you imagine, they have
units all around the country. So, if it's
education, it would be schools. If it's the
home office, it would be police stations.
If it's health, it would be hospitals.
And in these units, the local management have
a rule that if anything occurs on their patch
which could possibly generate bad publicity,
they have to inform his press office in the
center, somewhere close to here in Central
London.
And then they produce what's called a "Forward
Line" that they put into their computer in
the press office, so that if a journalist
rings up and says, "Well, what about this
embarrassing incident in Nottingham or wherever?"
They've already got their answer prepared.
Now the reason he was telling me this is he
was saying, "We never use it." 'Cause what
the press are writing about are the stories
that we select for them. We give them the
stories and they write them. So, and he said
just recently in his department, there had
been a little incident in one of his--whether
it's a school or a hospital or a police station
or a prison--where a married couple, a man
and a women, were running in this place together.
And they'd had an argument and on the work
premises, the man had taken an axe and attempted
to chop his wife into quite small pieces.
Now, that was a story worth reporting for
one reason or another. So they'd done their
Forward Line and we never got to hear about
it. In the meantime, they set up a photo opportunity
with the Minister, talking about them putting
an extra £10 million into producing tarmac,
or whatever it is, and we turned it into a
story.
You get the picture. While I was researching
this book, there was a beautiful little example
of all this at work. Where this was the summer
of 2006 and the World Cup football in Germany
was about to start. And although it's riveting
to read my book, it's very boring actually
writing it.
So, I was--. [chuckles] So, you keep drifting
online to what's going on. So I went to the
Guardian website. And there was a story there.
And this story had been put out by the Press
Association. That's the biggest news agency
covering the United Kingdom. Absolutely dominant.
And this story from the Press Association
said that an English football fan was so nervous
about England's likely performance in the
coming World Cup that he had taken out an
insurance policy, which meant that he would
be paid a million pounds compensation if he
suffered emotional trauma as a result of our
boy' performance.
Now, it's a funny thing being a journalist
because you're always looking for things that
aren't quite in place, that aren't quite right,
'cause that's the clue that there's a story
there. So, there was something about this
story that was rather striking, which was
the guy's name, the football fan.
He was called Paul Hucker. Now, it just struck
me looking at that name that if you were Mr.
and Mrs. Hucker, and there is the lovely Mrs.
Hucker pregnant with child and about to give
birth and you're having the conversation about
what to call the child, you would know two
things.
First, that you wouldn't call it a name beginning
with an "F," or a "P," [whispers]because the
child would be a little Phucker. [regular
voice]So therefore, I thought, "I don't trust
this story." In fact, it turned out that Paul
Hucker had cruel parents. He really was called
P. Hucker. But nevertheless, on that false
clue--
[laughter]
I started looking at this story and there
are obvious questions. Is there really a football
fan this neurotic that he would really, seriously
need an insurance policy to go through the
World Cup?
Is there really an insurance company that
does these things? What's all this about?
Now, I then went to the idle journalist's
best friend, which of course you all know
is Mr. Google. So I put old poor Hucker's
name into your search engine. And he popped
up on several other occasions in stories,
in newspapers.
And always stories about insurance and always
about the same insurance company. And in each
of these stories he was celebrating the value
of the insurance policy he had got. So I phoned
the insurance company. And I said, "Could
I speak to Paul Hucker?"
And they said, "Yes. Putting you through."
I said, "Hang on a minute. I've got to write
him a letter. Which department is he in?"
"Public relations and marketing."
[laughter]
OK. So, this story is what you might technically
call "totally false." It is the PR man. He's
a nice guy. I've since had a little bit of
contact with him inventing a joyous little
tale that will run on PA and because we recycle
this stuff without checking, it will run everywhere.
So for the next 24 hours, I watched this story
spread through printed papers, news websites,
radio and television all over the United Kingdom.
And in the second 24-hour period, it went
global. You could see it all over the English-speaking
world, in Australia, in Canada.
You could see it in all sorts of foreign languages.
There was a 'me-me-me-me Paul Hucker me-me-me-me-me
a £1million" all around the world as journalists
recycle this stuff. And if you want to understand
why we told the world there were weapons of
mass destruction all over Iraq and all those
other things, Paul Hucker is as close as you'll
get to the answer.
It's that churnalism process. OK. Now, there
are all sorts of other things that go wrong
in newsrooms. I'm just trying to give you
the core of it. No, step back. Let's go to
WikiLeaks. I'm a freelancer. I sit at home
with a sort of finely-tuned eye for a story
with which I may be able to put some bread
on the table for my starving children.
So, I'm sitting there. You know the sequence
here is that it is alleged that a young US
soldier based in Iraq called Bradley Manning
removed cartloads of material. And it is interesting
from our point of view in this context that
had he tried to--this is all alleged, alleged,
alleged. Bradley Manning is an unconvicted
man and it's important we hold on to that.
But this whistle blower, whoever he is, if
he had tried to remove the quantity of secrets
which he was later to disclose in hard copy
form, he would've needed a truck and it would've
been quite obvious that he was doing it. You
know how the whistle blower is alleged to
have done it with.
Do you know about this? He works in a little
room where only a very few people are allowed
in this US Army base outside Baghdad. And
inside the base, there are some computer terminals
which are hooked into private, indeed secret,
communication networks.
One is basically diplomatic and the other
is basically US Intelligence. And his job
is to go in there and somebody will task him.
"Find out everything we know about such and
such a village, or such and such an individual."
And he dredges it up. OK. Now, this is not--.
This is funky American stuff. So, while they're
doing that, they're allowed to play music
through their headphones. So, he's watching
this stuff, this anonymous whistle blower.
He becomes more and more concerned that what
he's seeing is routine evidence of the United
States being on the wrong side of the moral
barriers, committing crimes, doing all sorts
of appalling things.
And he comes to the conclusion that the world
should be told about this. And so, when he--.
He's a big Lady Gaga fan. So he starts to
take in CDs, which are clearly marked "Lady
Gaga," but which are in fact blank. He slips
them into his computer, sticks in his earphones,
does a bit of lip sync, and starts downloading
small truckloads of secrets onto his CDs.
And he takes them out and he takes them out
and he takes them out. And he gets away with
removing more classified material than any
human being has ever removed in the entire
history of this particular planet. He also
succeeds, this anonymous whistle blower, in
conveying this information to WikiLeaks.
The job is done. However, there is then the
most ghastly security breach from the whistle
blower's point of view, where he becomes lonely.
He goes online and starts instant messaging
a guy in California called Adrian Lamo and
tell him, "This is my job. This is what I
do. Here's all the stuff, the Lady Gaga disks.
I've just disclosed all this stuff to this
white-haired Australian."
And the guy in California, who he's instant
messaging with, goes to the FBI. And this
goes on over a period of two or three days,
the IM-ing. And you can see on the third day
it's a different pair of hands on the keyboard,
asking him questions. And at the end of that
third day, Bradley Manning is arrested and
accused of being this whistle blower.
OK. That happened in May. Mid-June, I'm sitting
at home reading the paper. And there's a little
story in there from our friends at Reuters
that says the Americans have arrested this
guy. They've accused him of leaking massive
secrets to WikiLeaks and this man is now being
held in some sort of dungeon in Kuwait.
Now, just as an example of how churnalism
operates, that story has gone out from Reuters
all 'round the world, following the footprints
of Paul Hucker. And then journalists get onto
the next exciting adventure 'cause they have
no time to stop and think.
Because I'm sitting at home with my feet on
the desk and with the starving children and
all the rest of it, it's really a very, very
simple thing to say, "Hang on a moment. Perhaps
the story isn't that the man who's been arrested.
The story's the secrets." If it's true, there's
been this huge hemorrhage of confidential
information.
Let's go and find out about it. So, cutting
a long story short, I set out to track down
this guy I had never met, Julian Assange.
I told I had heard of WikiLeaks. And there
may have been one or two other reporters trying
to do this as well. But it is a striking fact
that on the whole, people didn't try to do
the story.
They just did the churnalism. You with me?
[Nick Davies clears throat]
It took four or five days to find him because
at that stage, Julian was very concerned that
he might be the target of some kind of attack.
So he was lying very low. So I contacted people
who I could establish had previously worked
with him and tried to motivate them to put
me in touch with him.
Eventually, after four or five days, one of
his associates called me and said, "Don't
tell Julian that I'm telling you this, but
he is in Brussels. He's gonna try and speak
at a press conference in the European Parliament
tomorrow." That was a Monday.
And it was late on Sunday night I got our
permanent correspondent in Brussels to agree
to go to the European Parliament building
on the following day. He listened to this
press conference, grabbed Julian, took him
into a small cupboard and said, "Will you
meet this guy Nick Davies." Julian says, "Yes."
I go out there on the Tuesday. And we then
had a long conversation, me and Julian. Which
takes us closer into our subject area because
I had to try to persuade him not to do what
he normally does, or has been doing, with
information, which was to post it on the WikiLeaks
website.
To argue that, journalism can help in a way
that ordinarily the activity on the internet
doesn't help. And it's interesting actually
that from the point of view this question
that Julian himself took very, very little
time to agree because I think he already recognized
that the WikiLeaks model wasn't working.
You know the Links part of it is a safe corridor
through which material, at least in theory,
can be passed to him without its being traceable.
I think that was working reasonably well.
What wasn't working was then posting that
material on the WikiLeaks website and imagining
that the world would come to it and analyze
it, download it, rewrite it, distribute it.
It wasn't happening.
It wasn't being looked at. It wasn't having
any impact and he knew that. And before I
started this argument, he'd already started
looking for ways to hook up with the mainstream
media so that it was relatively easy in a
sense for me to persuade him into this.
And let me just finish this through the narrative
and I'll look at the issues. So, we talked
for six hours basically nonstop. Blah-bi-da-blah-be-da-ba.
And it was a very discursive conversation.
And some of it was about this central thing
of should we do this, but also we were going
off into long loops about the contents of
the material, which he had, and exactly how
it should be used and da-di-da-di-da.
At the end of this six hour conversation,
we came up with an agreement. It turned out
that the secrets that he detained naturally
fell into four packages of information. In
fact, I can remember him telling me quite
early on in the meeting, he said, "One of
the things we've got is the whole, complete
record of every operation involving the US
military in Afghanistan since they went in
in October 2001."
And I went, "Holy moley." And so I said, "What
else have you got?" And he said, "Well, we've
got the entire US military record of every
operation they've been involved in in Iraq
since they went in there in March 2003." I
said, "Fuck."
[laughter]
And then he said, "And the next thing is much
bigger. It's an archive of tens of thousands
of cables sent by American embassies all over
the world to the State Department in Washington,
DC.
And this goes back over the years. Some of
them as far as 1966." Well, I'd run out of
swear words. This is just vast, vast quantities
of secret material. The fourth thing, which
was never quite as riveting, was the personal
files of the prisoners who'd been through
Guantanamo Bay.
Still, I mean, on a normal day a pretty exciting
leak. But on this particular day it looked
rather small. So, there were these four packages
of information. And what we agreed was that
we would set up an alliance of The Guardian
and The New York Times to process this information
and to publish it.
And part of the reason--. I'll explain it
to you. Are we all right for time? Yeah. I
was saying to him that I did indeed think
that there was a risk of some form of attack
on him. There were possibly, in theory, four
kinds of attack that could be made on him.
One was physical attack to try and kill him.
Both of us agreed that that was actually extremely
unlikely because US Intelligence agencies
may have a history of brutality, but they're
not stupid. And if in this situation you go
out and kill Julian Assange, you're gonna
create a huge scandal, worse than the one
you're trying to suppress and you won't suppress
the scandal.
It's just not gonna happen. Then, there was
the possibility of legal attack, that the
Americans would go to court and suppress any
attempt by The Guardian to publish and/ or
arrest all the people involved. Now these
were live risks. And this was one of the very
important reasons for linking in with The
New York Times because media law in the United
States is much, much more generous to journalism
than it is in this country.
This country's media law is particularly obstructive
of the free press. And it would be easy to
go to court and suppress publication. But
the First Amendment of the United States means
that it's highly unlikely to happen.
Furthermore, if by going with The New York
Times calculation was that Barack Obama's
White House, specifically wouldn't do anything
particularly aggressive to the most powerful
democrat paper in the United States. So that
there was a political as well as a legal advantage
to tying up with The New York Times.
And that also had an influence on our thinking
about the third kind of attack, which was
a technical one that they might try and, I
dunno, crash his website or do something spooky
to his servers. In the same way, if you think
of it politically and you're linking up and
forming a powerful alliance in the United
States, it's less likely that they're gonna
do something like that.
But what we really knew, what this was really
about, we were launching an information war
going back to what I was saying about journalism.
We were provoking an attack if we publish
this stuff from the most powerful news manipulation
machine in the world.
If you look at the PR industry, look at the
American government. They're absolutely at
the top of the pile. It's massive. OK. So,
we had those different kind of lines of attack.
I'm slightly getting lost here as what I'm
trying to tell you. So we agreed that we would
create this alliance, go through these stories.
A few days later a dash of people gets brought
in and off we go. We do this thing. Oh, I
just wanted to tell you this one tiny little
thing. But this is just, it's color. We agreed
that the first package would be the Afghan
war logs. And I needed to get those back to
the UK immediately.
We were both somewhat worried about security
and so we agreed that we wouldn't use our
phones. So for example, my girlfriend called
in the middle of the meeting and she knew
I was meeting Julian. So, I had to say to
her, "It's all a disaster. He won't cooperate.
He's useless. He hasn't got anything." Just
in case we were being listened to. And with
the same kind of logic, there was a concern
that if I took a laptop or a memory stick
back through customs the next day into the
UK, I might get stopped and they'd nick it
off me.
So, Julian came up with--. 'Cause I'm a dinosaur.
And Julian understood entirely how to deal
with this. He said, "OK. Here's what we do.
I will create a website. It'll exist only
for a few hours. I will place the Afghan war
logs on this website. It will be encrypted
and you will have a password.
So you go back to the United Kingdom and then
you get access to the website." So, we're
sitting in this cafe. And he then took one
of the paper napkins on the table, which had
the commercial logo of the cafe on it. And
so with a burrow he hooked together some of
the words in the cafe in the logo.
And I then put that in my pocket. That's the
password. He did the same, put another in
his. So if I get stopped, 'cause I'm going
back into the UK, it looks like something
I'm gonna blow my nose on. It doesn't look
like the biggest leak in the history of mankind.
[laughter]
And so, it was achieved. We downloaded it
and decoded it and da-di-da-di-da, off we
went. OK. I just wanted to stand back a bit
and make the points, which is that if you
compare what happens when you simply post
material on the internet to what happens when
journalists deal with it, you can see that
we bring value to it.
In the first place, what he was handing us
was raw data. And what we did was to find
meaning in it, what we would call stories.
This was just an endless log of tiny incidents.
And it's only when you word search it for--.
We started off, for example, searching for
civilian casualty.
And we found examples of civilian causalities
which hadn't been reported. That's to say,
Afghan civilians killed by coalition forces.
And we discovered that they use one of those
wonderful US euphemisms. They called it an
'escalation of force' when they murder the
family trying to fight through a checkpoint
or something.
So we started searching on 'escalation of
force'. And while we were looking at that,
you see, as you pull that together you're
beginning to get a picture, story, meaning.
We also came across references to civilians
sometimes being killed by a particular outfit
called Task Force 3-7-2.
So, if my particular job was to research TF372,
and they turned out to be a unit which was--at
least part of its function--was to assassinate
people, which I think in any country in the
world remains illegal. But they were going
out and targeting Taliban leaders in villages
and killing them.
And very often in the process of killing them,
they would kill the dozen nearest civilians
to them. So, there were details in there.
So, you're converting raw data into stories
by finding meaning, patterns. So that's the
first thing we did. The second thing is that
to some extent, we were able to check.
So there was an underlying question here.
Is it possible that this material is completely
phony? That somebody is trying to set up Julian
Assange and WikiLeaks and/or us? And this
is all bullshit and when we publish it we're
gonna be the world's greatest laughing stock.
After The Guardian- New York Times alliance
was formed, about a week later, Der Spiegel
for various reasons came on board. And that
was a good fluke because it turned out that
they could get access to a massive US military
material, which had been provided to the German
Parliament in order to debate the future of
their involvement in Afghanistan.
And I believe what they did was to take random
time slices and compare the material that
the German Parliament had with the material
which we'd been given. And there was 100%
overlap. So, we were able to check that it
was authentic. So, the second thing we give
after meaning is credibility. I've forgotten
the other two.
[laughter]
Oh, I know. This is very important. [chuckling]
The third thing we do. So, meaning, credibility.
The third is that we can make the material
safe. Now, very, very early on, within 24
hours, the journalists who were dealing with
this, that's me and a couple of others at
The Guardian, very quickly realized that there
was some material in this Afghan database
which we couldn't publish.
It would be unsafe. There were actually two
different kinds. Some of it was operational
detail about how coalition forces do their
job, which might expose them to attack by
the Taliban. You don't want dead soldiers
on your hands. Not at all.
The other was that it was clear that there
were reports which described US military units
going into villages, which were named, and
identifiable individuals giving them assistance.
It might be quite low grade, just to say,
"Yes. The Taliban were here last night.
There was a group of them. They stayed in
that house and we know they've gone on to
that village." And the fear was if you publish
that then some old guy with a white beard
who is identified is gonna be dragged out
of his house and have his throat cut. And
you can't do that.
Right. This became a huge problem because
I was responsible for liaising with Julian.
And about three days into this whole thing,
I raised it with him at a follow-up meeting
in Stockholm. And he said a most extraordinary
thing. He said, "If an Afghan civilian helps
the coalition forces then he deserves to die."
And he went on to explain that he regarded
them as collaborators, informers. Now, this
was a--. Then other journalists had similar
conversations with him. It became a running
problem throughout the period of research.
And the problem is partly a moral one. You
can't publish stuff that gets people killed.
It's also a political one. If we're going
to make this alliance with The New York Times,
fend off all forms of attack within the information
war, what you can't do is publish stuff that
gets people killed.
If you think the main form of attack we were
anticipating here was propaganda, PR that
would be fired at us and we were saying to
each other weeks before publication, we know
exactly what the Americans will say, they
will say 'by publishing this information,
you are helping terrorists'.
It's perfectly clear. That's the obvious thing
they're going to say. And it doesn't matter
if they say that because we're not. We're
telling the world about civilian casualties
and murder units and all these other things
that genuinely they need to know. We're not
helping terrorists.
But, if he puts stuff on his website, which
gets people killed or could conceivably get
people killed, then we start to lose the information
war. Can you see? It's such a powerful PR
line. Such a powerful stick to beat us with.
And right at the end, in the last week before
we published he agreed to withhold 15,000
documents from this huge cache of 93 on the
basis that that would protect people whose
names were in there.
We publish. For 48 hours, it was extremely
exciting. You could almost hear the world
talking about these issues which we were raising,
these stories which we had found. And that's
why journalists are journalists. You want
impact. It was very exciting.
And I think it was on day three that The London
Times, owned by Rupert Murdock, hostile to
The Guardian, published a front-page story
in which they said, "We have found material
on the WikiLeaks website which can clearly
get people in Afghanistan killed."
And then the whole story started to unwind
as this powerful PR machine moved in. And
then they encapsulated it in a single line,
"WikiLeaks have got blood on their hands."
Now, it has to be said that we do not know
of any case of anybody actually being killed.
But in political terms, in PR terms, the damage
was done. The fact that there was material
there that could get people killed was extremely
damaging. And we started to lose ground in
the information war. OK. So, what I'm saying
is we can give it meaning.
We can give it credibility. And we can make
material safe. Nothing that we published has
ever been said to have jeopardized anybody's
life. And the final thing that we do is that
we give it impact. That The Guardian's website
now is getting 50 million unique users a month.
The New York Times is a higher number. Der
Spiegel is enormous. It's been up 120 million.
So, when you publish simultaneously on those
three websites you hit an awful lot of people.
And then in the wonderful world of the internet,
it carries on. So, I'll stop talking and let
you, but I just want to summarize it.
Here's how I see it. Any medium of communication
is liable to be abused. When I was a child,
the first television set started appearing
in sitting rooms. This is in the mid-1950s
in the United Kingdom. And all the Mamas and
the Papas said, "Isn't it a wonderful thing?
Now our children will be educated."
And now, television is full of shit, isn't
it? It's full of low-rate, lowest common denominator
commercialized garbage and a little bit of
good stuff. In the same way, I believe our
perception of the internet will change. To
see it as in many ways an information sewer.
It picks up and distributes falsehood just
as far and just as fast as it picks up and
distributes truth. And nobody checks. And
nobody makes sure it's safe. It's just out
there. I don't suppose we'll get to talk about
this now but it's a microcosm of that.
The second chapter in this WikiLeaks saga
is what happened in Stockholm when Julian
Assange had a dispute with two women, which
led to their going to the police. And that's
the simple truth about that. A dispute between
one man and two women who were supporters
of WikiLeaks, who adored Julian.
Something went wrong between them and they
went to the police. Now, I do not claim to
know what went on in those bedrooms. I wouldn't
begin to say that Julian has committed a crime.
I don't know the facts and I don't understand
the law. But what I'll tell you is this.
All of the claims that that incident is in
some way the result of a conspiracy by the
Pentagon, or the CIA, or dark forces that
it's something to do with dirty tricks, all
of that is built on a series of statements,
every single one of which is false. And that's
the microcosm of it.
Those statements have run through the internet,
particularly through Twitter, being conveyed
by people who don't give a damn whether or
not they're telling the truth. They don't
give a damn about whether they destroy people's
lives. The damage that has been done to the
reputation of those two women who've been
widely smeared, but one of them in particular
as a CIA agent.
Two of them have been smeared as guess what?
Feminists. Can you imagine anything more appalling?
How those women will survive in emotional
terms, or professional terms, I do not know.
It's been disgusting to watch it. Really,
really offensive.
And then what is particularly offensive to
me, coming back to "Flat Earth News" is of
course, that started flooding into the mainstream
media as well. Just as a single example, I
must stop talking, in amongst the many falsehoods
that have been put out about that incident
by Julian Assange and his closest supporters,
which includes his lawyers in Sweden, where
he was found guilty of misleading the London
court, a simple, simple thing.
He stood up and said in various television
interviews, "This smear against me is so effective
that three out of every four pages on the
internet which mentions my name, also mentions
the word rape." Now, how long would it take
any human being Tweeting, or any journalist
writing a story to check that?
Less than a minute to use your search engine.
There's Julian Assange and the last time I
did it, there was something like 37 million
references. So, if three out of four pages
also include the word rape, when you add that
you're gonna get something like, what is that?
About 29, 28 million. And do know what I got?
Two. So it's an exaggeration ten-fold. But
that simple statement so easy to check ran
everywhere in the internet because nobody
out there is even attempting to check. They
don't give a damn. And it ran through the
mainstream media because we don't check enough.
But compare the two really rather lousy performances.
I'd bag the journalists over the internet
any time. OK. Thanks for listening to me.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: We'd love to see you when
you're fully fit. [chuckles] Great. We've
got about 20 minutes for some questions. I
just wanted to kick off with one question,
taking you back to journalism.
I think all of us recognize the problem that
you're describing. I think the question is
who is to blame for this situation? And in
short terms, am I to blame? Or are you to
blame? I would suggest that journalism has
it. Journalism newspapers have a great deal
of responsibility.
If you see any story written about Google,
negative or positive, you will see about a
thousand replications of our story around
the world in which you describe. And it seems
to me that journalists are wasting an awful
lot of time just duplicating massive amounts
of stories.
Wouldn't it be far, far better to perhaps
take modest use from one simpler source and
then spend more of your time digging in and
doing good stories, pulling resources--. Who's
to blame for this problem?
>>Nick Davies: You're like a bloody journalist
tucking two stories into one.
[laughter]
Two questions. No. So, the first question
is who's to blame? I think I see in the balance
of things, it is more the journalists than
the PR machine. I mean, if PR is actually
lying, then I think we should give them a
great big moral kicking.
Where all they're doing is to select the truths,
I think that we should be in a position where
we say, "Actually, we're not interested in
the story. You've chosen to serve up for us
today with these pretty little quotes and
photographs and everything neatly arranged
for us.
We're going out and finding our own stories."
And occasionally, there will be an overlap.
We'll take your story 'cause in our judgment,
that's what people need to know. But because
of our vulnerability, all this structural
problems I'm talking about, we fail to do
that. So, we fail to defend ourselves against
you.
And I think we're structurally likely to be
manipulated by you. So, it's not the fault
of the individual journalist. Journalism is
full of good people doing a bad job because
they work for bad organizations. But the bad
organizations are bad because of those commercial
problems.
What was the other thing? Oh, yeah. And I
think we could make life a bit better if we
were a bit more honest with you. The obvious
thing we should do is that when we receive
a story that's running on one of these wires,
news wires, watches or whatever, we should
simply take it and put it in the paper.
But what we do is we take it and then rewrite
it and put a staff reporter's name on the
top of it and then put it in the paper. Now,
that is A: a complete waste of time, as you're
suggesting, and B: it is also dishonest in
respect of our readers because we haven't
been out and gathered this story.
We haven't checked it. I mean we might conceivably
have made one phone call and tack a quote
on the end, but why bother? I agree with you.
I would like to see a world in which we said,
"OK. There's a bunch of stories that everybody's
covering, so we'll just run the agency. So
that frees up our time to go out and find
some other stories which are much more important
that really reflect the values of the paper."
It's very distressing to see the way that
the newspaper's focus in on a tiny number
of stories and all report the same stories,
while failing to cover masses of other stuff
which is fascinating and interesting and important.
You ask yourself for example what's happening
in the reporting of the UK at the moment of
the poor.
So, depending on how you measure it statistically,
between 20 and 25% , probably the population
of this country can reasonably be described
as poor. There was a report recently about
how 27% of the children in Manchester are
living in not just poverty, but severe poverty.
That means not enough food. That means improper
clothing. How much time do we spend reporting
the lives of that fifth through a quarter
of the population? Almost none. The Guardian
I think uniquely has a reporter who is dedicated
to covering poverty in this country.
And that's good for The Guardian, but it's
not nearly good enough. I think we should
have at least a fifth of our staff out there.
Whereas we cover the world of the rich, look
at all the celebrity bullshit and OK and Hello
and all these people are pumping it out through
PR so it's designed to make them look like
better people.
It needs to use a technique that's especially
bullshit. So, I would love it if we would
run more agency copy, free up time, go out
and find different stories, not the ones that
everybody else is running.
>>Male Presenter: Right. Here's a question.
Sir. Go ahead.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Right early on,
you mentioned that 12% of stories showing
that they had their facts checked.
>>Nick Davies: Right.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: How do you distinguish
between someone who has checked their facts
thoroughly 97 times and not included, not
cited their sources or not included references?
I mean, in scientific journalism, it's very
common in the paper that people actually want
to see who you've called to check those.
>>Nick Davies: It's a good question. And because
I didn't do this, the academics in Cardiff
did it, I don't have a particularly good answer
for you. But I can answer it in this way.
That when we published the book, most of the
newspapers in Fleet Street went berserk and
were extremely aggressive in trying to pull
it apart. And they particularly attacked,
or tried to attack, the research that had
been done by these four academics in Cardiff.
And they never laid a glove on them.
I mean, there was an awful lot of hot air
and insult, but they were not able in any
case to say, "Look. Here's a story which you've
logged as being unchecked, but in fact it
was." But how quite the detail of the methodology,
I don't know.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Hi. Thanks for
giving a new synonym for blogging, journalism.
>>Nick Davies: What was that?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Blogging. The technical
industry is full of what you're describing.
>>Nick Davies: The tech industry, yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: The tech blogging
industry. So, you know this is kind of a recent
example. So what I'm thinking about is that
what was it like in the 1800s?
What was it like in the 1700s? Is this a new
phenomenon in journalism, or are we losing
our touch over a few hundred years or before
that? I mean, Rome must have had something
similar.
>>Nick Davies: What do you mean? Is our tendency
to put out stories which are false or distorted
new?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Yeah.
>>Nick Davies: The pattern has shifted. So,
if you go back to the 17th or the 18th Century
when the term hack was invented, journalists
basically had press cards for the same reason
as police officers in Kenya wear uniforms.
It's a means of extracting money from people.
So they would sell themselves to politicians.
If you give me enough money, I'll write a
story in your favor. It was completely financially
corrupt. Now, financial corruption among journalists
is very, very unusual now.
I can think of one case that was going on
in the New York Post that was very--. So it's
changed. If you go through the long era where
William Randolph Hearst kind of proprietor,
Beaverbrook, these were often people who owned
newspapers for political reasons.
Beaverbrook was completely explicit that he
owned papers like The Daily Express in order
to make propagandas. So these are very politicized
owners. And so therefore, the world isn't
necessarily a better place, but it is very
much a different place.
And what happens is that that generation of
politicized propagandists gets replaced by
these big corporations whose primary interests
is commercial, not political. And therefore,
the nature of the damage they do is different.
So, it would be extremely difficult to quantify
which was the age of least reliable information.
We don't have the raw material going back
over those years. But it's very important
to recognize that it's different because most
MPs, when they talk about what's wrong with
the press, are still using the Beaverbrook/Hearst
model. They still think it's to do with proprietors
telling us to write false things.
And it isn't. Therefore, any solution that
they might come up with, for example to do
with how many owners own the press, will miss
the point. I've said in the book that it wouldn't
matter if Rupert Murdock resigned and was
replaced by Rupert Bear. His newspapers would
carry on, publishing false stories because
it's structural.
[whispers] PR.
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: I'm interested
in your thoughts on the phone hacking scandal.
And in particular, it seemed to me that the
story got stuck until The New York Times got
invested in it and moved it on. And why did
it take a US organization to move on a British
scandal?
>>Nick Davies: OK. You're right. So, we started
publishing stories about the phone hacking
in July '09. And we were met with a combination
of two things. First, from almost all of Fleet
Street, complete silence.
No other newspaper wanted to run this story
because most of them also had been doing similarly
illegal things, and/or they supported the
Tory party and didn't want to upset Coulson.
The second thing that we were confronted with
was, as I mentioned before, lies.
There was some really bitter lying told by
News International and a great deal of concealment
from Scotland Yard and from the Press Complaints
Commission. So, we kept publishing stories.
I would think that between July '09, when
we published the first one and September 2010,
when the New York Times published, we probably
ran 20 or 30 stories.
And we were beginning to tear holes in the
official version of events. But it was just
us. And we felt not just that we weren't having
an impact, but also that we were politically
very isolated. We were still very vulnerable
to the smears and lies that were going on.
So, I would've told you this some time ago,
but as things become public, my editor contacted
the editor of the New York Times, Bill Keller,
and said, "Look. There's this fantastic story
here. It's got the Royal Family. It's got
private investigators. It's got tabloid journalists.
It's got law-breaking. It's got useless cops.
It's a great story." So, they then sent people
over, a team of three who spent five months
working on it. And again, it's all right to
say this now. I think it doesn't matter, but
I briefed them endlessly. I mean, I was giving
them so much information they started calling
me Nikipedia, 'cause I was the go to source.
[laughter]
So, we worked on it together. And they were
very good journalists. They did a very good
job. And there were two things that happened.
A: to my great relief, they confirmed that
what we had been saying was true 'cause there
was always the horrible risk that they say,
"Actually, you've got this completely wrong."
And they came up with several bits of new
information. Crucially, do you remember they
got one--. I had about a dozen News of the
World journalists who were talking to me,
but all off the record, terrified of losing
their careers. And they got this guy, Sean
Hoare, who's a lovely bloke, to come on the
record and say Andy Coulson, the Prime Minister's
right hand man, knew about this.
Now that's a brave guy. And he got smeared
'cause he had a problem with alcohol abuse.
So, instantly they bring that out and start
trying to damage his reputation. But anyway,
so I don't think it would be fair to say it
took an American news organization to do the
job because it was a partnership between the
two of us.
It was more a question of spreading the story
out. And since then, if other journalists
come to me for help, I help them without limit
really because I don't want The Guardian to
be isolated. And what really counts is getting
the truth out. And now, we're on a roll. I
mean, they're in retreat. Does that answer
the question?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: It does, but why
didn't you publicize the cooperation then?
>>Nick Davies: Because, I said in brackets
that I don't mind doing it now, but I wouldn't
have done at the time, we were working in
a very hostile, very political landscape.
And one of the things that the News International
was saying was, "Oh, well this is just The
Guardian.
They're liberal. Ignore them." And they were
winding up Tory MPs to attack us and they
were saying that to the--. There was an irony
here that they were complaining that the only
MPs who were complaining about the phone hacking
were Labor MPs. But that was because being
somewhat politically motivated, they had targeted
Labor MPs.
Therefore, they were the victims. Of course
they were most likely to complain. So, at
the time, we didn't say the New York Times
have been working in partnership with us because
it would have left us isolated with one other
party. But as it was, we got through that
phase. Do you think that was wrong?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: I think it brings
up the question about transparency.
>>Nick Davies: Yeah, 'cause you see--.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: The WikiLeaks stuff
was very public about the cooperation, so
you knew who all was working on it.
>>Nick Davies: Well, yes and no. See, I don't
think journalism is necessarily transparent.
It's a game. One of the differences--. Julian
talks about scientific journalism.
Everything, all sources must be disclosed.
That doesn't work at all. I spend most of
my life working off the record. I've got so
many secrets in my head I've stopped talking
to myself.
[laughter]
So, and you have to be able to work off the
record and say to people, "You're my source,
but I won't disclose it." And in a sense,
that was what was going on between what the
New York Times and The Guardian.
To some extent, we were a source of information
for them. They then went off and did their
own work and discovered several crucial things,
particularly Sean Hoare, that we hadn't got.
So we were an off the record source for them,
except that now we--.
>>Male Presenter: PR company. It was effectively
a PR company, except that they were checking.
Sir.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: So, the statistics
of 12% of stories appear to be fact-checked.
Do you think, or maybe you have facts or at
least you have an opinion, that that implies
that there's some core group of one in eight
journalists are very good and they almost
always fact check and everyone else is terrible?
Or is it closer to the other end of almost
everybody only fact checks--?
>>Nick Davies: I would think--. I mean it's
not a question we tried to answer, but based
on my experience in newsrooms, I would say
the answer is it's circumstantial. I don't
know very many people who went into journalism
just to fuck up and tell lies.
People go into journalism. Actually, it's
one of the few good things that's happening
in our profession. It still attracts very
bright, energetic, idealistic people who want
to tell the truth about important things.
And so, if you give them the chance they will
do.
So, I don't know, in a random kind of way
on Monday morning they get a chance to do
their story properly. They get the whole day
to work on it. And they produce something
good. On Tuesday, they give them five stories
in a single shift and they don't know whether
they're coming or going.
It's random. Just depends on the circumstances
in the newsroom I would think.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: I was gonna ask,
you talk about shifting patterns and two quick
questions. You talk about shifting patterns
in journalism. Where do you see this changing
in the next five years?
And the second question is we all know about
the phone hacking scandal. We all know the
sort of garbage that Fox spits out and yet,
the viewership, the readership of The Sun's
just increased. People watch more and more
Fox News. How can you explain this from the
consumer point of view?
>>Nick Davies: What was the first question
you asked me?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: The first one is
the future of journalism in five years.
>>Nick Davies: Oh, not a big subject at all.
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: What's the role
of the journalist in five years? And the second
question is--.
>>Nick Davies: Why are these things so popular,
the crass? Yeah, OK. So, let's take the first
thing first. See the future of journalism
under two headings. If you look at it purely
from a journalist's point of view, you couldn't
work in a more exciting time by comparison.
Before the internet came along, I wrote stories
for a newspaper which maybe printed 400 thousand
copies. And within 24 hours, that story had
gone. Now, we've got these 50 million unique
users hitting the website and furthermore,
my story is there forever as far as we know.
So the potential impact is great. It's really,
really exciting. If my editor was here, he
would underline what he calls the mutuality
of journalism, by which he means cooperation
between the professional journalists at the
core and the whole network of readers and
others who can work with us on stories using
Twitter or crowd-sourcing or whatever it is.
So, I think journalistically, it's the most
exciting time in the history of the profession.
But, heading number two, commercial. We're
in terrible, terrible trouble. So, you probably
know if the internet relentlessly takes away
our readers to websites which give news or
pseudo-news for free, therefore they won't
pay to buy newspapers.
And if what you're trying to sell is general
news, they also won't pay to read it on a
website. The only exceptions to that are when
news organizations sell highly specialized
information which isn't available elsewhere.
So our income from our readers is drifting
down.
Every single newspaper in this country. Almost
every newspaper in the developed world. And
in addition, possibly even worse, we're losing
our advertising revenue. So, there was a single
12-month period recently where The Guardian
lost 25% of its advertising income, just as
an example.
The biggest employer in Europe is the National
Health Service. That used to be, I think I'm
right in saying, our biggest, single source
of advertising. Whenever the NHS wanted to
hire a doctor or a nurse or administrator,
they would advertise in the quality press.
That's big, big bucks. Now they have a website
and they put it out there. It doesn't cost
them anything and they precisely reach the
market that they're after. If the NHS are
watching, I think it's a very bad policy.
[laughter]
It's a very, very strange time because what
I'm trying to describe is the internet has
broken our business model. And nobody knows
what a future business model for journalism
looks like.
And yet at the same time, we're all having
a party because it's a fantastic time to be
a journalist. So, it could be, I don't think
in five years’ time. I think if you look
20 years into the future, it is conceivable
that journalism will be dead, that the profession
won't exist anymore because there won't be
a business model to sustain it.
There is no God-given rule that professions
have to survive. When was the last time you
came across an arrow maker, who used to be
quite big chaps? So, and if there's a business
model out there, if any of you can see it,
tell us 'cause we're looking.
>>Male Presenter: To be honest, a whole other
subject. I hope you can get us back to debate
that subject for a sec.
>>Nick Davies: There's something about popularity.
Well, there's been a seismic cultural shift,
hasn't there? Really since 1979 in the way
that people perceive themselves in the world.
I mean, it's shifted away from people thinking
about themselves politically.
So when I was at university, it was commonplace
to talk about class and capitalism, even in
the mainstream media. It was commonplace to
hear people define themselves in social terms.
I'm working class. I'm a trade unionist. And
all this has drifted down and being replaced
by people's perception of themselves as consumers
and their interests in the world have changed
accordingly.
And so, because of their commercial organizations,
the kind of subject matter which we cover
has changed away from--roughly speaking--political
news towards entertainment stuff--Big Brother
and reality shows and soap operas and celebrities.
You get a huge shift.
And that's something to do with Thatcherism
and Reaganism the destruction of socialism.
I would say that the fact that socialism has
been taken out of the mainstream is absolutely
crucial part of that big shift. So you've
now got a demand for pseudo-news, for news
as entertainment, for garbage instead of the
real thing.
That leaves a significant minority of the
population, probably all the people in this
room, who care about the world and want to
know the truth about it. So, it would be wrong
to paint the whole world as having gone down
the drain in that way. There's still a significant
minority who we're trying to reach.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Just thinking about
the role of journalists, it seems as if journalists
are required to do more things these days
than they used to be, like print journalists
who maybe used to have to know how to do shorthand
and type, now maybe having to use content
management systems and so on.
TV journalists are having to maybe edit their
own material or film themselves. Do you think
that's true and if so, if you think that's
had a good or a bad effect on the reliability
of having to spend time fact checking?
>>Nick Davies: It's a problem. It's particularly
clear in television news where it used to
be the case the reporter would go out with
a cameraman and a sound man and then once
they put together their piece, that would
be edited back at base by somebody else.
That reporter will certainly no longer have
a sound man. He may be carrying his own camera
and then he's expected to edit his own footage.
The result? He has even less time to do his
work properly. Even less chance that he'll
go out and find a significant fact that hasn't
already been reported and even less chance
that he'll check those facts that he is collecting.
And that's driven by commercial--. It's a
good example of commercial considerations
damaging the editorial function.
>>Male Presenter: Do you have a last question?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: Is the story over
for Andy Coulson or is there more to come?
>>Nick Davies: On the phone hacking?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: Yeah. Does his
departure effectively answer that kind of
consequence?
>>Nick Davies: No. So, if you can measure
it in terms of time span, we're probably about
two-thirds of the way through the phone hacking
saga. It's got another 12 to 15 months to
run. And the engine that's now driving it
is no longer The Guardian.
It's the new police operation. Operation Weeting
at Scotland Yard, which finally, finally has
done what the two predecessors failed to do.
It's put serious resources in. It's there
to take on the most powerful news organization
in the world. And it's investigating. Now,
we don't know whether they will come up with
evidence that shows that Andy Coulson was
in any way complicit in crime.
And it's important to say that we haven't
found that evidence and that as things stand,
he's an innocent man. But if anybody is going
to do that, it's going to be Operation Weeting,
who I now trust. I didn't trust it when it
was set up, but I now trust them. I think
that they're doing a straight job with a lot
of resources.
If it turns out that Andy Coulson was guilty
of complicity in crime, then that will reflect
to some extent on the Prime Minister. I don't
think it'll reflect quite as much as some
back bench Labor MPs want it to, but certainly
they'd be entitled to say, "Well, your judgment
wasn't that great. And for Christ's sake,
this guy had resigned for this scandal. Shouldn't
you have checked?"
So there'll be some questions, but I wouldn't
have thought they'd be particularly powerful
or lethal.
>>Male Presenter: Thank you very, very much
indeed, Nick. We got some low value PR freebie.
I don't know if it'll suit you in any way
whatsoever, but thank you so much.
>>Nick Davies: I'm so moved. Thank you.
[applause]